HOI LAM: Wear OS
by Google supports
many cross-platform
development options
by default, such as
phone notifications
and Actions on Google.
But what if you want
to do more and tailor
your experience for the rest?
I'm Hoi Lam, and I will walk you
through the development options
for Wear OS, a
wearable operating
system by Google for everyone.
Before we begin, it's important
to note that Wear OS by Google
is based on Android.
So many of the things that you
know about Android development,
such as the concept of
activity or services,
the use of Android Studio, or
the distribution for the Google
Play Store should
be familiar to you.
There are three
options if you want
to tailor your app for Wear OS.
Wear apps, watch faces, and
complication data provider.
It is not an either/or choice.
You can package one or more
of these within the same APK.
So let's briefly go
through them in turn.
A Wear app is a good
development option
if the user's journey can
function better on the wrist
rather than on their phone.
Great examples of this includes
exercising, contactless
payment, and messaging.
Creating a Wear app is just
like creating a mobile Android
app, with a few enhancements
for the wearable form factor.
This includes round screen
support for our resource
qualifiers, or [? round ?]
[? aware ?] classes,
such as boxings and layout.
In addition, for longer
user interactions,
such as shopping lists,
exercising, or travel apps,
Wear OS supports ambient
mode, which reduces
battery use and screen burn-in.
Another way to develop for Wear
OS is to create watch faces.
If you are interested
in creating
beautiful and functional
timepieces, this is for you.
Showing the time is one of
the core aspects of a watch.
And as a developer, you can
bring your unique style right
to the watch face.
By overriding the onDraw
method in the canvas watch face
service, you can draw lines,
shapes, or render bitmaps
through the canvas
objects provided.
If you have created a
custom Android view before,
this should be familiar to you.
What if your user wanted
more than just the time?
For example, what if they wanted
the latest news, the battery
level or even the weather?
Being a connected device, and
with the user's permission,
Wear OS can supply
data from Google
or other third-party
apps to your watch face.
These extra pieces
of information
are known as complications,
a traditional watchmaking
term describing areas
of the watch face
that are showing information
other than the time.
Watch face developers can take
advantage of the complication's
framework to make their watch
faces not just beautiful
but highly functional as well.
Lastly, developers can choose
to implement a complication data
provider, which allows
the app to share data
with the watch face.
This is especially
suitable for apps
that have key information
the user would like
to see on the watch face, such
as share prices or weather
information.
This is a great way to dip your
toe into Wear OS development
if you already
have a mobile app.
Development of a complication
data provider is simple.
Just think about one
key piece of information
you would want to show.
To get started, create a
complication provider service,
and supply the data
requested on demand.
You can also ask the
system to request
an update when new
information becomes available,
such as a new chat message,
or a piece of breaking news.
To conserve battery, Wear OS
may reduce the update frequency.
A good rule of thumb is to
think of the complication update
intervals being on the order
of minutes rather than seconds.
As I said at the
beginning, there
are a number of development
options available on Wear OS.
From cross-platform support
for notifications and Actions
on Google, to Wear
applications, watch faces,
and complication data provider.
The choice is yours,
If you're looking to enhance
your existing mobile app,
create a complication
data provider is probably
the simplest way to get started.
Just follow this code lab.
For more information, check out
the Wear OS developer sites.
Happy coding.
[MUSIC PLAYING]